and she says oh guess guess who's
playing pippin in lord of the rings
it's not you it's not you you didn't you
mean
[Laughter]
hello everyone hola mis amigos
spore and paul you know george is oh i'm
sure he's around here somewhere
what's his name george lopez george
lopez
oh my god omg omg bye
oh my god
what makes it more dicey is there's a
small house
that's connected to a driveway to the
tate la bianca the la biancas that were
killed by
charles manson's gang and charles manson
was in the
home that night with a connective
driveway
right and that's that fountain at the
junction of los
feliz boulevard and what is that
junction where riverside yeah riverside
that's where they came down and washed
their hands and feet after the murder
oh no way yeah a friend of mine told me
that they come down from that hill
and the closest water source is that
huge fountain which is still there and
they wash their hands and feed yeah what
are you doing where you're at
you're missing all the oh
[Laughter]
the guy left the girl left the mom left
her sunglasses
and the waiter said hey i'll take him
and he's walking up with the sunglasses
and then
he's better on next door the lady yeah
the lady
saw oj run a red light and look at her
and give her a menacing look she sold
her sort of hot copy she was out
can't be a witness if you sell your
story to hard copy
have you met oj yes how's that oh let's
start there yeah i played golf with oj
oh after he was acquitted so he spent
some time in him
he was playing at norwood which is in
granada hills and this planet handsome
damages in the valley
but oj played the atnt he played at
riviera country club over there
in pacific palisades they played the la
open there
so oj was used to kind of playing
anywhere oj wanted to play sure
so then after he was acquitted non grata
got kicked out of
you know riviera nobody would play with
them they started to play in the valley
and nowhere in granada hills on balboa
near uh rinaldi
and then he played a handsome damn which
is
on the fifth hole right over the fence
is where rodney king got beat by the
lapd
right there and the guy george holloway
or holliday
had bought a camera that day this is how
it all started
he bought a camera that day when people
started to buy their own personal
cameras right
so he buys it and then he opens the box
plugs it in
then he takes it out of his balcony he
says let me see how how i work this
thing and what he catches
is the end of the chase and then he's
videotaping
the beating and he can't believe what he
has
and he calls the foothill division of
the lapd which is the foot of the
division
they they were the jurisdiction of when
i was growing up and they they were
had a reputation of being being hard
asses
right and george holloway calls and says
hey has anybody recorded any issues of
police brutality tonight
and the desk commander says you know no
but you know
it'd be nice if you would mind your own
business yeah
so he hangs up and his next call is to
channel five
and says i have this video and they said
hey bring it in
and then they see it and then it's it's
on
channel five and it changes the way that
we look at
yeah police work yeah and videotapes
change the world in a lot of ways and
just one guy who brought home a
camcorder
and just charged it and said let me let
me go on my balcony and see
that's gnarly man that's nollie is he
still with us rodney king
no he died right he drowned he drowned
and he had some significant health
problems post the attack right but
what you just went swimming one day and
i i mean i mean
i'd like to think it's more than just
that i mean i don't you know
so he wow that's crazy i think you know
and it's essentially because you know a
guy like rodney king was
first of all i mean all of the things
around that were like the hyundai was
going 115 i'm not sure if hyundai
you know when they found out they said
i'm how fast it goes
it's
so much of it became what is
what it's evolved today like you know
they moved the trial out of los angeles
to simi valley and simi valley was more
about
was not l.a so so the jury i think was
more of a one-sided thing but
you know it changed that was 90
it was almost 30 years ago right so
but that's not why we're here i mean but
it is good
yeah we should do intros yeah
interesting uh very excited to have on
uh to the podcast today we have billy
boyd dominic monaghan
uh miss monahan
you know if you had the you know the
butter pat monahan from train
right right i don't think they ever say
monique what did you say
it's all right there is a g in there but
it's it's i could have taken it out
but then i think there's another actor
called dominic monahan with the with the
g
taken out there's a like sag rules yeah
in britain you can't have you can't have
the same name can you
that's true was there a william boyd
there was a william boyd when i came out
of drama school
there was a william boyd working in the
uk he was on a show
called eastenders right okay
very big show and he was like the bad
guy
on eastenders and i was like uh yeah i'm
going to have to
change my name so i was going back to my
mother's maiden name and there was
somebody there
which is what uh manly so it's going to
be william manley
quite cool but there was somebody
william manley so then i went to my
uh dad's or way back then there was a
striking in there so it's going to be
william strachan
but then william boyd and eastenders
died no
he forgot to pay his union jews wow oh
no way
i took the name boom you're in oh snipes
brilliant
okay you know i know he said there's
from the show extras
but eastenders was a fabulous yeah
what would what's the equivalent of
these standards in the united states
as they're one um well it's it's the
beast
because which is a bit you know whatever
they say doesn't sound as insulting
is there one in england or is there ever
before
in in england i mean we're not including
scotland here because scotland had
crossroads which is their own
soap opera take the high road take the
high road
but in england the two big warring
soap operas for the past 50 years well
40 years because eastenders not been
around for that long
yeah was coronation street out of
manchester when i'm where i'm from
and eastenders out of london where you
know
most other people and certainly
londoners are from
east enders tends to be a little bit
rougher around the edges right yeah
they deal with drugs and stabbings and
stuff and in coronation street someone's
lost a dog and a cat's gone up a tree
and someone's fallen into
a well which was another show similar to
another and ian mckellen
who plays gandalf in lord of rings loves
a coronation street and actually went
and played in it
as a character after lord of the rings
he did a couple of months as a character
because he loves it
and also his mom his mum was a massive
fan right and i'm not sure if his mom's
still with us i think she was the last
time i spoke to him his mum is very old
and she's a huge coronation street fan
so we said i'll go do that you've had
some big
actors in coronado street tom courtney
was in coronation street who was a
massive actor in the in the 60s
in eastenders who's the big breakout
characters from eastenders so i'm going
to say that
no one i'm going to apologize because
there is no show
like those two shows in the united
states well like the young and the
restless is that not
no it's i mean general hospital i guess
it just i feel like there's so so much
more clout
to like an eastenders or even a
coronation streeter yeah like that
right but you know that's kind of being
old you know there was edge of night
like that was but they ran its course
you know and as the world turns
what's the biggest telly novella of all
time
oh i got nothing there's a lot of them
that
i got is there not like a benchmark
thing that's like that is the king and
everything else gets out of the way
you know if my grandmother hadn't passed
i probably would be able to tell you
because it was always on in the other
room
yeah yeah yeah
do you remember there was a point where
the simpsons was the best show on
television and the most dangerous show
on television
and now it's a little passe right yeah i
think you know if you look at
family guy and american dad
[Music]
where an animation you're able to get
away with quite a bit
more yeah but it doesn't mean that
it's less edgy yeah i don't think you
could do it in
in a human body but you can do it as a
as an animation
yeah yeah then it's a legend they get
away with i was watching drugs
everything
did you guys know love and death and
robots i love death and robots yes i
i was just watching so it's kind of
short form animations some
somewhere between 12 15 20 minutes david
fincher's involved robert rodriguez is
involved the animation's incredible but
they deal with quite edgy
stuff i mean there's death and there's
murder and you know it's kind of
how do humans deal with technology in a
modern day world it's fantastic it's on
netflix fantastic
oh have you heard of that billy
george um before i go into that because
i haven't
so the reason we're here is to try your
beer right
hold on is there a cold one i've got
more so we have yeah
well it's got a good noise to it last
time i saw cheers cheers guys
huge fans of yours this is kind of an on
like by the pool
type beer like yeah absolutely
absolutely yes
how long have you been um we've been
brewing for about a year and then the
restaurant opened in
hermosa about a month ago and then i got
a place in torrance what's the
restaurant
it's bruce all oh it's fantastic yeah
thank you we've got to take a drive to
the restaurant isn't that great i was
down in torrance the other day i should
have went in
this one this one is a biscuit it's a
little sour but
i love it what they started to do with
this is starting to put
a little bit of tequila on the rocks and
then using this
almost like someone would use red bull
with vodka and it works that way tequila
is my jam if i if someone's if someone
put a gun to my head and said you have
to drink one drink for the rest of your
life
alcohol what do they do with tequila and
that would they
they use it almost like you know as a
mixer
as a mixer to the la familia
some ice and this on top and it
that's beautiful you have to take some
i'll give you some of this to try oh
that would be great now so you're a beer
fan
george this is something that you've
absolutely
these aren't cold but that one this
one's called
that's just that one's not cold yeah but
the ones we have are cold these
those are like i will give you the taste
and that one reminds me of a dreamsicle
the 50 50 bar
yes when you were growing up that has
orange on the outside and cream in the
middle
that was the genesis behind that
something for your son to show
have you have you partaken of any
british beers
i was drinking tenants uh quite a bit
tennis
classics i didn't realize that
i heard on a show somewhere it's almost
like drinking you know complete lead
but uh when i went back to scotland they
didn't have it
at well saint andrews has changed quite
a bit st andrews
has gone from as a golfer
saint andrews went from kind of the home
of golf
sure to a destination
around the home of golf okay where the
quaint places
like the [ __ ] in on 17 now you go in
there everybody's a bit younger and
they're all wearing the same shirt
so it went from kind of place where
every time you went you saw the same
person
to more of a upscale
and then the place seemed more of a
almost like cabo
where uh everything is kind of a resort
around they built a new four seasons
by the new course and then now it's
it's not you won't get lost in there
anymore
right because it just became a place
where now it's a destination of golf
when was the first time you played saint
andrews the first of its place in
averages was 2008.
and what is it the greatest golf course
or is that just based on traditional
home of golf
so it's the tradition of it or is it
aggression it's a great course and it's
still a great course as well yes
it's a hard course that's what makes it
so great oh yes and the course
which we don't have ghours like i mean
the course is just uh
his ball got caught in the gorge but it
was like waist high
so he said you know i'm gonna i'm gonna
hit it like swinging a baseball
because he didn't move it i mean you
could play it and he swang at it like
waist high like
like hitting was it like a heather well
it's like no because
thick sticky sticky yeah it's not
sticky you wouldn't want to fall into it
so that's part of the character of
saying andre
you've got the wind blowing wind and the
rain and the conditions
people who are playing over here are
used to hitting these lovely big shots
and then but you get to see andrew you
had up there as a way over there
and then on that on the beach there they
they filmed chariots of fire so they're
running on the beach they're running on
that
yeah on that beach right there so go on
bills and it was uh
saint andrews was the first job i got
out of um drama school uh st andrews
used to have a
rep theater repertory theater or you
would go there
for you know the six months whatever it
was and you would do a play at night
rehearse another one during the day it
would run for a couple of weeks then you
do the next play
and it's still one of my favorite jobs
brilliant just
doing a play at night rehearsing going
to those wonderful bars around san
andreas
playing some golf brilliant and is there
is there a particular hole at st andrews
that is kind of
the the one that people do the 18th hole
is the one where there's you know there
people stand and watch every day but 17
the the road hole is the one that is
right up against
the saint andrews uh hotel there
so the professionals because they're a
little bit further back that they have
to hit it
over the hotel wow and then it comes up
on the other side so they would say
towards you know the corner of this
now when i played there i headed into a
wedding reception up on top
and then i went in there and looked at
the dent on the side and i bought the
the bride and grew up by the dom
it went rifling through their their
their their party
they could have killed someone
[Laughter]
i went in there and said you know i
apologize i'd love to buy you guys a
bottle of champagne
that's brilliant didn't i read something
that tiger woods
had only ever played there during you
know huge championships and
and he knew where he to aim where he hit
the ball
because of where the cameras and
everything where all the
so when he played there without all that
he didn't know how to play the course
because he's like oh wow that normally
aimed for
yeah one of the most amazing things is
of of any golfer
is that tiger woods won the british open
in 2000 and they have
every golfer has a guy in the group that
carries a rake
and if you hit it in the trap he'll rake
the trap
and he'll continue with you and in 2000
tiger won the british open
at st andrews and did not hit it in the
trap
once and that's
impossible that's legendary have you
played with tyga
uh you know i met tiger in 1997 in
february
the la open was in town i met him at the
lab factory still pretty nice enough guy
and then he won the masters in april and
then i've seen him around a little bit
but
you know i think everybody knows how
difficult it is to be a person i guess
of that
yeah right iconic yeah yeah
where i could say alleged i mean
michael jordan and charles barkley were
friends of his and
you know when a guy
is trying to be maybe cool i don't think
you use charles barkley and michael
jordan as
your yard markers because basketball
fame
is different than golfing but also tiger
was a bit
of an introvert and a bit of of
of a not a ladies man per se right
right so i think he got a little bit
over his head right
because i remember uh charles saying
alleged
you know do do you don't try to do us
right we're
we're pros and we're in a different
business they are literally bowlers
that yeah they're both yeah and he's in
the business where they tell everybody
to be quiet
and jordan and barkley are bizarre
but it definitely you could see where
did you see the
hbo documentary yeah yes tiger i mean
obviously the shadow of his father
looms very large in his life right i
think the passing of his father
probably sent him into a tailspin right
and then he's got all of these
distractions with money and women and
his
incredible talent you know he's a
fascinating guy it's fascinating yeah
even when we're talking about last time
that even what happened to him here
with no breaks and those skid marks is a
bit of
i think almost you'd hate to think that
you know
because the in there it starts the
second part starts with him getting
pulled over
and he didn't know where he was yeah and
then and then
earlier this year he gets an accident he
kind of doesn't remember that
kind of didn't know where he was right
so it could be alleged you know
prescription drugs but it's a it becomes
a real issue
yeah i mean he's lived in pain for a
long time right
that footage of him hitting that was
drives and his knee falling out
and hear the bones yeah they were saying
the the people close him said they could
hear a crunch of like
as his knee falls out i saw charles
barkley at a laker game the end of april
of 2008 and then i said you talked to
tiger because he had your surgery and ty
and charles said that [ __ ] guy's
gonna play in the u.s open on a broken
leg i said hey man
there's no reason for you to play he's
like [ __ ] that i think i can win and he
won i mean one on the monday but
then another it's not like the the us
open isn't like where you play three
holes
and then you know you decide a winner if
your tie on sunday
you have to come back the next day and
play all 18 holes
so it's not like you might you know win
on the second player
but i'm fascinated by pro athletes i'm a
huge football fan
and you know i like i like any uh like
high element of sport the olympics
nba you know any any sport where you
have the best of the best i'm always
interested
in that but what's what's the
fascinating thing that i
watch as an outsider looking in is
the mentality stays the same with all of
these guys but their body eventually
fails
so you're watching someone who thinks i
can do that i used to be able to do that
and you've got this crazy battle going
on where their body goes we can't do it
anymore
so with tiger for the longest time it
seems like he said i'm just gonna have
my force of will take over and then
eventually his knees and his hips are
just like
tiger like we can't keep going you can't
think yourself new cartilage
right yes already you know a few
surgeries in even by the time you got
out of high school
but did you see the maradona doctor
documentary
genius you're a football fan obviously
south america so where
you support mexico out here no from
mexico yeah and
so the mexican national team you support
but what about a city team or
um you know i'd say you know i'm ellie
aztec
they were around
and you're just amazed that they're
running around for that whole time
maybe a minute or two this guy wasn't in
there and then you realize
the beauty of what it's a world game
yeah you know they say world series
they say you know the the super bowl but
it's nothing like not the world cup
eclipse
my trainer who i've been training with
for like 20 years now as
big athlete played basketball at school
played baseball
liked soccer but never really played it
and
i've known him for 20 years and over
that over that time i said to him
because i'm always referencing messi
because messi's like on some genius
level
jordan tiger woods though and i said it
just watch one thing that messi does and
try and replicate it like
run as fast as you possibly can and
bring a soccer ball with you
it is impossible let alone all of the
tricks and the movement and
the the changes of direction and we went
out to a park one day and i just said
just try that
kick the ball in front of you and try
and sprint and keep the ball with you
and he was like i don't understand and
i'm like
no one understands messi no one
understands maradona or cruyff or all
those people
would kick it with the leg between his
other leg and under like a goal yeah or
even his penalty kick
where he didn't even think about it he
walked up yeah
and in one movement hit it and made it
in above the net in the corner
yeah and without even thinking of it so
as the goalie you're standing there
and you don't even get a chance to do
this because he's just he's just you
know leisurely going up what
and it's over you can and you can't get
it when he was like
12 13 get like boca juniors were like
circling around him getting ready to
sign him and giving him money obviously
keeping him on the books
they would boca juniors would bring
maradona on at half time and he would
juggle the ball
with a golf ball he would do keep you up
and then with a glass
coca-cola bowl he would do keep-ups yeah
onto his knee
onto his chest down onto his knee again
like what are you talking about that's
just transition he's genius
how does that um you know do you think
people do you think people
are aware in their in their time of
like i'm you know i turned 60 so i would
say from maybe
20 to 50 of all the things that i saw
that were great
a lot of them athletes are and and
because of maybe social media
and somebody's good and somebody's good
but there's always somebody that's
really great you think people really
understand
the genius of some of these people if
they're not athletes or actors or
no i always feel like there's you know
until you do something you don't know
what you don't know
and so like you can see someone like
like messi or ronaldo or something like
that and they do something insane you're
like wow that's crazy
but to your point it's like you take
someone out and you're like try doing
one of those things
running and once you learn like how hard
it actually is then you even
understand even better like once you
start playing guitar then you realize
how hard that solo was right and i'm
also fascinated with the you know the
rory mcilroy's or or the
scotty pippins or the cristiano ronaldos
who have spent their entire life
being the best and suddenly they see
tiger or suddenly they see jordan or
messi and they're like
oh my god everything that i know about
who i am who i identify with as a human
is now being compromised by the fact
that i'm number two and he's clearly
number one
there was one year that ernie else came
in second place in
all four majors and uh you know he's
from south africa
uh ernie so he's like well these i think
tiger man won three so you're like
well if he wasn't around i won three
and maybe i think he's won just a
handful but
if those guys that came around in that
in that era of tiger winning 15
i know lee trevino liturino was a jack
nicklaus killer like he said i could
beat nicholas
he goes and i didn't hit it that far and
then i remember we played with a guy and
he bombed it and he told that guy if i
hit it that far nicholas would be a
pharmacist you know because
he goes i never hit it that far but i
always found a way to beat yeah like i
wasn't intimidated by him
and that that's uh it's it's a rarity i
think and especially i think maybe
as kids all get trophies
that when you play like they want maybe
everybody to kind of
be the same it's it's tough to be good
when they're not keeping score right or
tough to be good i always thought that
it was difficult because
i i always came in second and never won
a championship but it made me try harder
now if everybody ended up
the same would i have tried as hard even
though i always came in second
right i mean what what is what inspires
you to be
better if knowing when you sign up
you're already going to get an award
right here's here's one that um a coach
said to my son
my son was big big in soccer loved it
and uh he just quit to be a skateboarder
now he's just
skateboarders is all he does you know
he's california you know
but he loved football he loved soccer
but he was having trouble getting enough
speed
so he had a coach working on you know
getting faster
you know and this this coach was a kind
of not olympic level but
really really great sprinter this uh
woman
who was teaching them and she said she
was a a club
and there was two of them a girl who
always won and then she was always
second
and she was at this big state you know
race
and she's she's getting set up to go and
she said her coaches at the side you
know try to get her and the girl that
always wins
you know because they're get they're
against the best people in the state
yeah
and he looks at her and and says to her
like you're going to be second you know
that's great you're going to be second
and she said i looked through it and i
just said victory he's sending me
victory and she said it just changed my
headspace
and she beat that girl and beat her
every time from then
because before that she always had the
headspace of
okay i'm i'm second in the state because
i'm training with this girl who's
amazing
but when she saw that she just changed
her headspace and totally
she went over to him and said you said
victory right he went no i said second
and she
fired him never heard from him
it was in disgrace now anyway it's back
to tennant's lager
oh it's the best right you know it's
killed many people george i drank it
i drank it wherever i could get it and
then i took
i told the guys at carnostia at the
country club i said hey man do you mind
if you give me a couple of glasses the
tea glasses and i said they said yes of
course
i said i'm starting a talk show in 2009
so i did the talk show for two years
and every day i did the talk show
my glass that i had on the set was my
tennis class
and then i went last time to the [ __ ]
and i went scotland you couldn't you
i couldn't find it in those places
because
because of the change i think because
they're getting expensive italian lagers
yeah it was gone my dad worked his whole
life in tennants
so i was in tenants all the time because
you know
if it was bring your son to work or
whatever
[Laughter]
every friday he would arrive he wore a
long coat
and he would arrive i always remember
and he takes cut off and he had
tenants cans all around his belt
so he had like 10 cans of tenants
stolen out there
but who owned it and what was the
percentage of
this wasn't lead-based i don't i don't
think i don't even think it's the
alcohol
i think whatever chemicals it was lovely
isn't it that's just the best it's a
great beer
we have about three or four four days of
of good weather in scotland
as you know a year and sitting outside
with a pint of tenants is oh my god
it's my favorite i wasn't um south korea
doing a thing and i was walking past a
bar
and they had the t tenants
i went and and i sat there and they put
they had
music on um records record players
and somehow it was some scottish bar and
i sat there with a tenants in
in south korea a slice of home oh my god
it really is amazing but it's still in
full production right
it's still in food for the day it's
gotta be the biggest beer in scotland
still right
i would think so i can't think of
anything i took a picture on the balcony
and and it had a tea underneath the
glass and as i'm drinking it we took a
picture underneath so it's me
here with the tea under taking a drink
and it's brilliant
my favorite have you had have you had
have you had boddington's
i'm going to represent manchester um
boddington's out of manchester
so so boddington's was i think it was
the first
if it wasn't the first beer it was it
was closely followed after
guinness that had what's called a widget
at the bottom
of the can just like this when you crack
the can
here it releases a gas that creates the
foam and boddington is a very creamy
lager
it's a not a lager a nail yeah so what
do they have is the bottom
is it uh is it not smooth
or is it a gas wait they said about the
way they carved the
glass it's actually because i've done it
before i've dismantled the can and
looked
inside it it's basically a little
plastic canister
that when you release the top here it
opens it
and it fires a whole bunch of air
through the beer creating a head
brilliant technology and a really really
yummy beer boddington's they feature on
the tv show friends
quite a bit because they go to london
and joey and chandler end up drinking
boddingtons and then they bring it back
to
new york together i'll tell you what's
going to be a good beer though
george lopez
we all like you guys cheers man you guys
know your beer
[Laughter]
george let me ask you this because i'm
fascinated by stand-up comedians and
going back to the thing that we talked
about with
in terms of like the best of the best
type thing i know shows nowadays are
different for you because
you do your own show and that's your
thing but back when you were younger
and kind of on the circuit and doing the
comedy store and the laugh factory and
stuff like that
can you remember a specific time
where a comedian went up and you thought
i'm in real trouble here because he's
brilliant and i'm not sure well here's
what i saw here's what i saw so
i wanted to be a comedian from the time
i saw freddie prince cheek on the man
senior
you know and um
richard pryor of course xi jin chong but
i used to listen to richard pryor
the live in long beach which he did like
79.80
and then in 80
there was a canary yellow rolls royce
idling in front of the comedy store on
sunset by itself
on the in front of it kind of near the
big room
and then there's the the room you can
see from the street you can look into
so there is a canary yellow rolls royce
and as people get out
they go richard pryor's in that car and
they're like what and you look over
there
and behind the wheels richard pryor so
my buddy ernie goes go and say hello
like nobody's really going over there
so i kind of walk and i cruise and i
look in i get a little bit closer i'm
not sure what i was going to do
but as i get closer i hear him
using a microcassette recorder and
listening to himself
and you can hear the laugh and you hear
he does it again then he does it back
again and does it again
and then i backed up and he goes what's
up
i said hey man i really saw everything i
needed to see i saw a guy
at the top of his game with a micro
cassette recorder listening to his show
back and forth in between shows and i
and from that point
i did that so i recorded all my shows i
transcribed all my shows
and i used that i didn't need to say
hello i met him later
but it's like seeing somebody who's
really good
when you wouldn't expect to see somebody
who's that good
still working on their right workshop so
he's still working yeah
he went to his car by himself with his
cassette recorder he's listening to
himself in between shows and you're like
that's what
right somebody's doing in the craft i
saw chris rock
at the comedy store years ago and
coincidentally
about a week later i saw him at laker
game and and went over and
spoke to him but at the at the comedy
store he got up it was
it was probably close to 11 o'clock at
night a lot of people had been on
he got up he had a little notebook and
he said hey guys i'm just
trying to work some stuff out here so
bear with me and you know he's kind of
looking down at his notes a little bit
more making notes as he's you know
telling a joke and stuff like that that
particular show
must have been his oscar show
presentation that he did because a
couple of weeks later he did the same
jokes at the oscars and i saw him at the
lakers
he didn't give a [ __ ] about who i was he
i was i had i was lucky enough to have
courtside seats
he had courtside seats as well he was
walking past me
and as he went past me i said hey man i
saw your shirt at the communist thought
it was fantastic
and i i said i really loved watching the
process
and he was like we we all do that you
know every comedian does that you just
sometimes you see a polish performance
sometimes you don't but he was really
impressive in the same way where i
thought
he's letting it all hang out you know
he's willing to show you
how it all works well george wallace is
a comedian who
he does vegas a lot he's probably doing
it 50 years so he would walk up with
a notepad and he would go the whole
world is sick
a lady went to the store she went in to
try to buy a hat
and they want to let her buy a hat
because
she and then nobody would laugh and he'd
take his thing and he'd go all right
[Laughter]
[ __ ] that one and he tried another one
and he has and when he laughed he would
go okay that's a good one
and when nobody left he'd walk over you
know all right
but even as a tool if that was a tool it
was it was a brilliant tool
because the the plus you keep
and when nobody left it was funnier
because you go all right
check that one out have you seen
comedians in cars getting coffee
yes jerry seinfeld and so i think it's
brilliant it's a brilliant idea you
should be on that show
when you when when i'm watching all of
these comedians on this show
i'm thinking okay well there's a gap
here there's george lopez here where's
joseph
yeah yeah what do you think about jerry
seinfeld
um i think seinfeld is is fantastic i
think he's great observational
humor wise um incredible but also
i would say if you look at seinfeld you
have to look at larry david
right who was not a performer but a
creator of that show
so larry david was
george costanza kind of right and larry
david knew a guy that was like
i think the guy's name was kenny kramer
right right so
a lot of it was larry david so it was
great to see seinfeld have his success
but also larry david to come into the in
which he hated
larry david hates being in public he
hates performing it's all of it like
when you see him that's who he really is
i saw him out there riviera one time and
you see a guy that's pretty much wearing
a [ __ ] beekeeper's outfit he's got
he's covered in canvas he's got canvas
gloves
and a thing with a net with like the two
holes in the mouth and you're like
it's kind of a sex doll but it's kind of
a
beekeeper and you go that's larry david
and you're like get the [ __ ] out of here
and you go up there and through the
mask you can see he's like hey george
hey what's up larry
and he hates the sun how do you know but
he loves golf
and and the fun one of the funniest
things he said is
because there's a thing in golf where
they say when you take a swing pretend
like you're throwing the club at the
ball right but larry would throw the
club at the ball
and then go get it and then have to come
back and hit it again
because he said to me you know you know
that thing george where they said you
throw the club at the ball
i go yeah he goes but i'm really doing
it so i take the club
and i hit the ball and i let the club go
and the ball's going straighter i go but
then i gotta go get the club
and then get another club and then do it
again but his
you know what nobody's ever done you
don't see anybody on the tour [ __ ]
throwing their club at the ball
and then having to go get it but he was
literal like he's like you know
i'm literal no but and there's nobody
really like him like that fellow
is great and there's a lot of guys chris
is great chappelle's
amazing but there's nobody that has the
amount of
this by the way like tiramisu of comedy
yeah there's so many
ingredients that have to go in there for
it to be good
that's him he's the only guy that i saw
at a party that i felt i had to go over
and say hello
you're very good at that you can see it
although and seeing hello
to people and
but telling people that you like what
they've done
i can't do it why what's the thing it's
a call but it's a cold read you're like
oh but who doesn't want to get told hey
i like your stuff you're fantastic
no no but when i was married my wife she
loved
uh sisters see the words and sisters so
you know
my wife goes up to see the word and
tells her how much she thinks how great
she is she's like
oh wonderful and just oh
that's a dragon maybe that's the thing
maybe i'm always dreading that
and i don't even know why i went over i
just had to tell them because i feel the
same way
yeah i feel there's there's something so
brave and brilliant about his comedy and
it just works so well
and you can watch it over and over it's
brilliant and i just had to kind of tell
them that in some way
and uh but you told me that he was
he was astounded that you knew what he
did right he was like what you you
watched that show and you were like yeah
i love that show he's like oh okay
i mean um i i just i i totally agree i
think it is uh
really something you know how great
larry david is i had him on my talk show
we were doing dna testing
and he had to come so we were doing dna
testing and then he had to come back and
get the results
and when he came back he found out he
was like you know 35
native american and then he goes
you know george now it all makes sense
and i go what do you mean it goes
because when i was a kid and i played
cowboys and indians
i rooted for the indies
[Laughter]
i want to be a guy because i always
wanted to be an indian i never wanted to
be a cowboy i mean this is amazing
talking about comedy and and and i know
you're meant to be interviewing us and
all that
i'm just i'm really interested that how
how does being a stand-up and you've
probably told this story hundreds of
times
you don't want to but being doing
stand-up and then getting your own
um sitcom how does that does someone
just see
you do you become like
you know how does that and then you know
could you how long did your sitcom run
that was a long time i said come around
120 episodes still on i mean you know
and you know um man
sandra bullock is the per really the
person that saw me
that said um you know
i think that there's something here a
guy jonathan comack
who today that tells you how he's the
first guy he's in iceland
so this guy is the first guy that ever
saw me before
sandra sami and this is today so he and
i stayed close and that's
20 years 21 years so he was working for
sandra
just as a friend going on looking at
talent and then
he had seen me and then a whole year
later came back and said
you know i have somebody that would want
to see you and it was her so when she
saw me
but you also have somebody that sees you
and stands behind you
that doesn't say you know if she brought
her ca agents to see me and they didn't
get it
yeah that she's not like yeah i tried
she stayed committed to me
and that was very rare to find somebody
like that
but i never imagined the sitcom i
remember seeing
drew carey get his sitcom and it was
like number one i remember seeing tim
allen
before who was hilarious in the clubs
and i was always a bit of a work in
progress so but when i got
to the point where you started to tell
the stories of your life for the show
it worked perfect at that time and i'd
been doing it for
21 years then but having a guy like
bruce helford who did who worked on
roseanne
who created drew carey and who worked
with me is you had a guy who was
knew how to take those stories and make
them into a show
which is dumb which is i think the
hardest part like you know
andrew dice clay had had a show called
bless this house
on cbs before king of queens and
dice was hot and he had bruce
and dice was like i don't know if it's
gonna be
like this maybe we shouldn't even have a
neighbor you know
so so he [ __ ] called les moonves at
home
on a saturday charlie sheen's friend uh
uh moonves right the head of cbs to
complain about the show
and monday [ __ ] moonves cancel the
show oh wow
because he had a star call him at home
which nobody really does
that's a that's a bold move and moonves
was like one bad news don't do it
don't ever call me no i would never go
no
you know and he's calling to complain
about
his showrunner wow and on monday
that's a heavy flex that's a heavy flex
i was at
i was at a uh doing my show
when a couple of people came to my table
reads said oh we have another table read
at 10 30 for a pilot
i forgot who was in it but when they
came back 90 minutes later
the president of warner brothers tv
peter roth
canceled the show after the table so
it's war it's like you might last a day
you might
you might make it to the end of the war
come back to new york and
ticker tape or you somewhere in between
right
it might be the end christopher titus
who had a show on fox
88 is the number to syndicate after the
last season they had 84.
i mean alleged i'm not you know whatever
whatever he is they didn't bring it back
just so they could say
[ __ ] you you'll never get the
syndication right
and he did 84. 84 doesn't do anybody
good petty business
88 i mean so much of this business
there's so much
that that phrase that we hear about
catching lightning in a bottle you know
it's so difficult to
make a movie or make a tv show or make a
podcast any kind of project
i've had friends over the years you know
kind of sit me down over a beer whatever
and be like
not involved in the industry dom
why don't you make a film that you're
the star of and just
write your main role and then give it to
a guy and
turn it into a film like do you have any
idea
how difficult that is like you know
obviously
bills and i met when we when we made
lord the rings
the fact that we could walk on set of
lord rings day
one the amount of moving cogs and pieces
just to get us to that place let alone
delivering day one
through today you know 350 or however
many days we got to
it's crazy so what was amazing about
lord the rings
i mean there's so many incredible things
about lauren is but one of the great
things that it seems
the entire cast seem to grab hold of is
how lucky we are and that we would right
there's no other place that we would
rather be which i think
came from pete because when we would ask
pete about him being tired and exhausted
and working night shoots and day shoots
at the same time and
all of this pressure he would say to us
there's nowhere else i'd rather be
i want to be a director making lord the
rings i'm on set doing it
let's go away and you know in reading
you guys in the i can have another video
information
please i'll tell you what's a good deal
how did you hear about how did you hear
about it first like
how did your agent call you somebody say
hey we have this thing for you to go in
on
i'll tell you george my best girlfriend
of all time
nick lived about eight minutes away from
my house
and we used to hang out at her house
because it was above
two bars that we liked so we would hang
out her house have a few beers and then
when the bars open we go downstairs and
keep drinking
and i was at her house one day we were
listening to
stevie wonder and the jackson five on
ray on uh record and someone passed me
a supplement a a a pull out
from the guardian newspaper sorry the
times newspaper
and the front cover of the times
newspaper was this iconic
shot of gandalf and frodo in the lord
rings and it said
on the cover of the newspaper pete
jackson
new zealand director set to make lord of
the rings trilogy and i opened it up
and i read that it was in pre-production
and at that point this is how far back
it goes and at that point
sean connery was the hottest tipped
actor to play gandalf
and gandalf was the thing that they were
building it all around and i sat and i
read it
i remember listening to steve wonder we
were listening to um
boogie on reggae woman yeah hi steven
wonder jeff an absolute [ __ ]
gentleman
and i said i was an actor at the time
i'd been acting for probably three or
four years and i said to nick
this looks amazing and that was it and
then from then on i had auditions and
spoke to my agent but that was the first
time i ever knew that it was going to
turn into a
into a film are you familiar with the
source material like where are you at
with the
book my dad is a huge fan so we lived in
germany as
kids and as we would drive from germany
to
england every christmas to see our
grandparents it was about
like a six hour drive you're going three
hours across germany
on a ferry three hours up england we
would listen to
the bbc ian holm recordings of
lord of the rings where where ian holm
played frodo which is
an incredible performance i went to
greece
a few years ago on my own to one of the
smallest greek islands it's called tilos
there's like 700 people live there
and i went on my own and i downloaded
this
recording which is like a 13-hour
recording to my ipod
laid by the ocean laid by the pool
listened to ian home after i'd worked
with him which is an incredible
experience
so i knew a little bit about we'd read
the hobbit i hadn't i didn't read lord
the rings until i was
kind of 15 16. my dad kept saying to me
you're not ready
it's it's you know it's a thousand pages
it's too big yeah
it's a commitment because i love the
hobbit i was like well if it's like the
hobbit i love it he's like it's not
really like the hobbit it's it's pithy
it's weighty
and then i read it when i was 15 16
spoke to my dad about it and then
had auditions you were the first guy
cast right yeah apparently yeah wow
before ian mckellen yeah i was um it's
one of you talking about uh sean connery
was this sean connery
no sean connery was he he did get
offered the part of gandalf
um and i met him at a dinner later
a year absolutely not
no question i love sean connery you know
you can't be scottish he should not love
sean garner he's amazing actor
incredible and i'm sitting with him at
dinner and um
i'm with like a politician the
politician's like oh sean tell
the story of how you were offered lord
the rings on and you could tell sean
didn't want to talk about it and i was
like oh god this is so embarrassing
yeah but apparently he just
he he didn't know a lot of rings and he
just didn't understand the script he was
like i don't get this wizards and elves
and apparently if he had done it it'd
have been the biggest contract
of any actor ever because they were
offering them 10 points or something of
course
he would have just be you know but um
yeah when i heard about it
every actor in britain that i knew was
was
auditioning for it everybody's going to
london and i just
you know i went down and they gave me
script pages for pippin
i read it and i remember i wasn't really
ready the way these things always work
out yeah
the ones that you don't really think
you've done well at i thought oh well
and i was doing a few auditions i went
to london for this all right
and then i got a phone call saying pete
jackson wants to meet you
went back down to london met him once we
did some scenes
and uh got cast i've done other things
that are like
small theater things musicals where they
want to see you nine times
yeah you're like i remember going for a
musical
and i was on the ninth audition and i
said to the there was a line of
producers and i said
this is it by the way it's not going to
get any better than this
this is what you're getting right yeah
it's either take it or leave it
you know nine times is my max i mean
nine times
whereas pete jackson you know he's i
think that's what makes him a great
director he makes decisions
really fast yeah yeah even on set
i remember i'm sitting you know
directing and there'd be a line of
people with
swords and cups and this is for you know
this is aragon sword
uh not that one that one this is the cup
for the
yeah that one just like decisions you
know yeah
so much of directing is just making
decisions yeah yeah yeah
yeah i think so but i think you know we
was thinking about this in the car but
the term
director could apply to like you know
alfred hitchcock it could apply to orson
welles but not
i think what he did was beyond like the
scope of
the you know yeah filmmaking yeah a
filmmaker
he's a visionary because you you have to
see things
with your eye first
and then you have to trust that your eye
is the eye of the audience and the eye
of the book and the eye of the
the the he has to keep track of things
they're not in sequence i mean
he also has to he also has to maintain
that stance which i don't necessarily
think
he is comfortable with in his civilian
life
of saying my word is final i'm the boss
and i'm gonna run with it pete in his
like
non-director life he's just very easy
going he loves the beatles he loves good
food he loves hanging out he likes to
have fun he loves practical jokes
he's a lovely guy he's very easy going
but at work
it's his word and he and he has to say
i'm the man around here and i i think
that is a really
tough position to be in as a director
especially when you're sensitive like
peter did he keep a lot of the same
capable of the same people as much as a
lot of his crew the people around him
he's so his first assistant director
when we were making lord the rings is
now one of his producers
so he basically you know if they're
great he keeps them and
promotes them unfortunately this the
cinematographer the dop on lord the
rings
passed away which i think was a massive
turning point for p
because they they'd made an
extraordinary amount of fantastic work
together and he died and that was
almost kind of his right-hand man but in
terms of producers and heads of
department
he tends to keep the same people right
yeah and just that that sort of
new zealand vibe you know have you spent
any time doing there george
no new zealand it's an amazing place
there must be some good golf courses
down there absolutely i think so yeah
it must be but he um that sort of
sort of family sort of vibe that they
have there where
even through the time that we were there
off and on for three four years
people will have started as drivers
and then they went on to camera and then
they might go from camera to sound
if you like someone it's not
specifically
i want you for that like if you feel
like you want to move around
he's totally up for that as well and i
think the last time
i was there they said that he's the
biggest employer
in wellington the city because
all the post stuff that he does now
special effects and all that she's got
so many people you know it's wonderful
yeah yeah he's an amazing guy yeah he's
amazing well such an all-encompassing
job to just life on set it's like if you
find someone and you like that person
probably as long as they can do the job
keep working with them
you know if they started driving then
did sound whatever yeah
i want to spend you know 15 hour days
that's a small amount of people so if i
can find someone
yeah i mean it's a double-edged sword
load the rings in a lot of ways because
an incredible experience for all of us
i'm sure
it's kind of compromised further jobs
for me
because i always base it on well it's
not
it's not the friendships i made on lord
the rings it's not the chemistry of lord
rings it's not the vibe it's not the
the feeling and you can never capture
that again but
we were all isolated on on this little
island
we all cared so specifically about the
project and the director and
and the source material and none of us
got distracted at a time where mobile
phones
cell phones were not really a big deal
you know the internet had just started
when i
left england to get to new zealand
there was a survey that i used to fill
out in my favorite music magazine at the
end of each year
and if you send it in you win it you win
a competition if they pull you out
and it was like you know band of the
year song of the year album of the year
album cover of the year and the final
question was website of the year
and i had no idea what it i got to new
zealand billy and i hanging out hanging
out with
you know everyone and elijah and orlando
and vigo and all these people
and within about three months not only
were billy and i aware of the internet
but we were consistently building into
our off days
a chance to go to an internet cafe so
that
slightly opened up the world but we were
still kind of
locked into this island mentality yeah
yeah
i'm not sure like the guys making the
new lord rings amazon film you know
amazon tv show in new zealand of course
i
i'm sure it'd be fantastic and and i i i
really
hope it is and i'll watch it i'm not
sure if they're going to be able to
be in that same isolated bubble that we
were because the world has now
changed it's changed where were you when
you found out you got it
i was i was doing a workshop
for a new play in edinburgh
and i remember uh it was it was the the
the theater was down it was a basement
theater and i came up
and uh oh they gave me a message you
have to phone you have to phone your
agent
i didn't have i didn't have a cell phone
so i went to a
phone box for my agent and my agent
who sadly has passed away now she was a
wonderful woman and she says
oh guess guess who's playing pippen in
lord of the rings
[Laughter]
yeah and it was just a phone call and i
was like and she said um
pete jackson wants to speak to you uh
tomorrow or something i was like okay
whatever time it was and i remember when
he called i was on the bus
going from glasgow to edinburgh to
continue on this play
and i was trying to be quiet as pete
jackson saying you know you know you're
going to be here for a year
and i was like yeah yeah i was like i'm
i'm on a bus i'm on a bus
[Laughter]
but you really were you're away that
long huh yeah
a year and a half straight through all
three
well kind of kind of it was supposed to
be all three
and pete did this brilliant gamble where
it was supposed to be
a year and a half so wait just to
interject it's october 99
all the way through to december 2000
which is that's only like three months
oh that can be right
wait is it that's 14 months
that was supposed to be all three movies
and um
those movies come on no so he
concentrated on the first one and he
didn't really have the second
he did some you know we did it all but
knowing that if if we have a success in
the first one
then the studio will throw money at two
and three so when the first one was a
success
they got us back to new zealand for like
three months or something
maybe more to finish the second one and
then the next year we're back down again
for four months to finish the third one
you know i remember crying at the rat
party
we had a crazy rat party for principal
photography crying hugging pete and
hugging his wife
oh god i'm going to miss you guys he
said you'll be back here in a couple of
months
i said yeah you'll be back you'll follow
me on the internet it's going to keep
it's ongoing i was like oh okay
sounds great it's so beautiful man
congratulations to both i mean it's just
it's just one of those things that
you know somebody has to come in second
you know when somebody auditions and you
you pick the one
today i was at a golf course and i saw
the guy that played my best friend on my
first show
he gave me a big hug and we've been
through so much it's almost 20 years
but i remember the couple other people
that came in
the three choices and he won and
you know you think about the other two
guys like this guy
it changed his life it changes your
family's life yeah the life of
yeah your children and stuff generation
really it's it's a big win
and they do make a lot of movies but
they don't make a lot of lord of the
rings yeah i mean i
i think my role was offered to someone
else before me and they turned it down
an actor called brecken meyer do you
know this guy
oh you can make it yeah yeah yeah he did
a couple of tell you what he's been
doing he was in uh he was
clueless right right right so as far as
i'm aware
he was offered it and he said i don't
want to go to new zealand for two years
it's not
in my game plan so they then went to me
and i said i'll take it yeah thank you
you weren't actually second i was about
10 or 11 actually
it makes sense yeah man i mean
like those things happen he's sliding
doors in actors lives i remember my
agent
sending me the script for the hangover
and
he said look this is going to be a big
hit this is going to be a studio movie
this is going to be a big hit
and i and i got him on the phone because
they'd offered me a part and i said look
this is a great script it's very funny
but i said
it's it's a piece of americana you know
it's it's it's marlborough lights it's
lucky stripes it's it's it's
coca-cola it's it's hot dogs it's
something that i'm not
born with it's something that i'm not
broke with i think an american person
would play this
better and he said well it's going to be
a big hit
there's a lot of heat behind it and i
said yeah i'm aware it's going to be a
big hit
it's not for me obviously the hangover
became a massive
smash so you have those moments as an
act and i think you just have to stay
philosophical you're going to make
mistakes
you're going to make the right decisions
ultimately as long as you're happy with
your choices yeah that kind of reminded
me of the conversation i had with sean
connery
when he gave up gandalf yeah yeah
imagine all the money you'd have got
done
well i think like you said he was i
think he was offered something like 10
points on the gross
which would have been hundreds of
millions if not billions did they offer
you that on the hangover
no they didn't carry on
you get to hang out in vegas though uh
but and he turned it down
yeah yeah yeah sean did well russell
crowe turned down aragorn as well i
heard
oh i didn't hear that i heard that we
obviously had a
an aragon that came out to hang out with
the stewart towns and
like rehearsed and filmed and learned
how to
you know work with a sword and sword
fight and do dialect training with us
and about
well it was actually at the end of our
first day of principle photography it
was the four hobbits
rolling down a hill realizing that we're
on a road
frodo has been told you're not supposed
to be on a road by gandalf and we
disappear under a wooded log and
the black rider comes on that day we
were all ushered into a room at the end
of
rap because we were told that the
producers and the director wanted to
speak to us
and they told us that stu stewart who
had been who would at
that point been been ready to play
gandalf
gandalf aragon for what two months
yeah a little bit more had been let go
so you just
you know and he's a great actor and he's
you know he continues to work to this
day
you just don't know what's going to
happen you know who took uh
michael j in uh back to the future eric
stoltz started
and there's some footage out there on
youtube you can find seeing them doing
the same scenes it's just
very so tim allen you know when he got
home improvement
he ended up using richard karn the guy
with the beard
but he was the second choice the first
choice was the guy stephen tablowski
who was in groundhog day the guy that
played the insurance guy
who was doing quite a bit of movies at
that time so in that time that they was
offered to him
he said well you know i'm doing a lot of
movies right now
and i'm not sure if you know i want to
kind of do tv
and he turned it down and they went over
200 episodes so
i don't care how many movies you're
doing yeah home improvement which is
number one
i remember tim allen was at abc and they
would say the number one comedy but the
number one company might be number 12
amongst the drama yeah yeah and he went
up there and said i was number one when
number one was number one
was the number one comedy right and that
guy turned that down which is just wow i
find it interesting
i find all of that he's had a
fascinating life tim allen right i mean
was he was he not like he was prison for
a little bit
for uh smuggling a bunch of marijuana if
you're
and if you're if you're in prison you're
in prison
i don't care why i wouldn't say i don't
care what prison
incarceration incarceration but i'm not
i don't think you're sitting by there
going
i'm going to be a star one day and have
my own show no i think
but i think tim is you know he's been
hasn't used as in
drag i mean during the show i think he
drank robin williams too as well would
tell me that when he was doing
more committee that he would like they
drink so much i'm not sure where the
devil comes from you know right that
that they would say to him they'd go
like this they'd go he goes this is how
he talked to me george
and he'd lay i'd late he goes lay down
on the ground then he'd go like this
robin so for after lunch
he'd lean over him and talk to him wow
and then and he told me that he's like
you know
he was you know he would always ask me
how you doing with this with the
drinking and i would say yeah you know
uh i think i'm okay but not like not
like those guys did were they right
he was a fan of rings so there was a few
occasions where
i met robin williams um
wait did we do charades yeah and so
we're in new york with the saturday
night live crew
and it was myself billy elijah and sean
and we did
charades with ed norton yeah robin
williams amy
amy poehler amazing
rudolph who was absolutely [ __ ]
hilarious
she was hilarious and robin williams was
just
like i'd never seen anything like it it
was just like he he'd been plugged into
the electricity you know he's gotta be
on the mount rushmore of charades
teammates
oh my god who's the best i think you're
good at improvising
until you're in there with those guys
yeah and he
he he basically did a scottish accent
from the moment
he heard me talk i mean you've obviously
heard him do the golf thing
yeah yeah yeah sure that is a great
sketch
when i was a young when i was a young
comedian there in nineteen
seventy nine eighty the common store on
sunset and there's
one door that goes from the smaller room
the original room to the main room
and you hear this thunderous [ __ ]
ovation
and the bathroom is by there so you
could really just take three steps and
open the door
and when you open the door he's in his
khakis
with his he came straight from work and
mindy so he's in his jersey shirt
with the with the suspenders and the
khakis
and he's oh you know he's doing this you
know when you see him do that you're
like what
what man it's like mork but it's robin
williams and he's
come from paramount studios brilliant
straight there
did you see jim carrey when he was
coming up i did see jim carrey because
he's a phenomenal talent and
as a young stand-up comedian the stuff
that he was doing was incredible
in 1991 when comic relief
was on just almost literally after the
rodney king beatings
or the beating of rodney king that that
thing and
jim carrey did comic relief and went up
there and did an impression of stacy
kuhn
the lead detect the lead police officer
who had a lisp
and he went up there and put him in his
stand-up
with the lisp and you're like how
do you that's crazy and and not ask does
anybody know what stacy [ __ ] is
one of the officers accused and he had
the list and if you heard him talk you'd
be like this is
this is him but the [ __ ] balls that
it takes to go and
do that he's brilliant he's brilliant
yeah he's
broke he's such an incredible shining
light berlin i've talked about jim
carrey over the years like
obviously his performances that they've
captured on camera ace ventura dumb and
dumber you can go on
incredible but some of the more raw
moments where he's in a stand-up comedy
club
and you capture him at that point like
his henry fonda impression
incredible clint eastwood mr charles
he's wholesome
yeah he transforms he's amazing and you
know it's funny because you know you get
a little bit like
i know that he bought a few houses
around them and it's a zen garden and
he's a little bit you know you you lose
a little bit i think of your
that spontaneity because as life hits
you and things happen
you're less of that but you know what
gave
jonathan winters the will to live was
robbing like
them doing things together when they
were on mork and mindy and they would do
the johnny
carson together like he
you know robin had a place to go before
he found like a mentor but i don't think
jim ever found
a mentor and somebody in that in the in
the comedy world
right right and it's tough to be that
guy right yeah
all the time yeah because eventually
i remember george clooney told that paul
newman towards
george clooney because we're all in the
corner there warner brothers
don't let them keep you inside like he
said don't ever let
you know your fame or fans
keep you inside right and i think i
think
jim was a victim to that of being yeah
maybe a little bit
being isolated yeah and you never want
to stay in right
george clooney seems to have it all
figured out yeah yeah i mean he's always
the fact that he said he wouldn't get
married again and he found somebody
who's incredible and has children and
stuff he's really
and they live in italy and he's not
interested in any of this [ __ ] he
just lives in italy brings up his kids
does a movie or directs a movie when he
feels like it he seems like he's gonna
offend him
it's weird though because like you know
we've hung out with a lot of those
kind of people but to be honest george
when we work together and we've been out
for one night right
i don't think as i've seen anyone
getting
as much as you did i like i wasn't i
honestly wasn't expecting
them right these are your people yeah
well i got to fight in [ __ ] hooters
i went home before that but i've never
seen people were so wanting to get to
you
that i'd never i've been out with like a
lot of people
that don't get that sort of maybe it's
because it was a bar
or something but you you like didn't get
a second we had it we had a good time we
had a good time out there
it was good and you were good at like
okay and you took
like 45 minutes out the evening to say
hello to everyone and then it sort of
diluted it and it kind of
you know and i thought that that was
really smart but
i don't think of because normally you
see people looking over but they're not
they're not coming over whereas
everybody just came at you
well was that hard for you like you're
talking about you know george clinton's
saying you know don't keep it
don't keep him inside or whatever did
you ever deal with that because you
obviously at some point had to go from
you know young george to where are you
in the world i'm going to tell you i'm
going to tell you you know i grew up
very disconnected and i think i still am
you know i like
you know i i play golf and you know i
i don't i'm not dating anybody i think
you know if they say don't let them keep
you
in i think i've i've i've stayed in
like um i want to saw pat monahan from
train on thursday i went to the desert
he was going to be out there's a friend
of mine
and on thursday night they were going to
have dinner i didn't go i knew i wasn't
going to go
and then friday i played golf and then
saturday i came back and yesterday
i stayed in all this so so today i went
to that but but
i'm a victim of uh don't let him keep
you in
it's not that it's it's a pain in the
ass i just kind of always kind of been
in you know so it's a it's
but do you enjoy your own time
to be around people and be
me i sometimes feel like if i'm actually
gonna be
a hundred percent who i'm supposed to be
it's too much for people
right i'm a little intense i'm a little
highly strong well here's the thing i'd
rather be on my own and not
not exposed but if you guys wherever you
want in the world and it had to be
interesting because this is a
this is a movies and stories that
eclipse just you know not the united
states
now you're this is you're in a global
franchise right so wherever you guys
would go people would look and go oh
wait a minute oh [ __ ] and it's
everywhere right yeah
that takes a bit to get used to yeah i
think the worldwide thing was
was weird like you would go anywhere i
can't
go on vacation without being like no
one's gonna see me here yeah i remember
going to mexico
and and just after like the first or
second movie
and people like in the middle of what i
thought was nowhere really quiet
and a cafe and someone would come over
and you're like really
weird this you know yeah i was in tokyo
with billy and elijah one time
and liv tyler's boyfriend
at the time called me up in my room and
said
what are you doing and i said well we
don't have anything until tonight
and he said i'm gonna go watch brian
wilson uh
record i was like brian wilson from the
beach boys he said yeah he's here in
japan
i was like oh okay i'll come so we
walked around this
do you not know this story no but the
hell we walked around this area of japan
where he had been told go to this
address and they'll let you into the
recording studio
and we couldn't find it so we spent like
two or three hours walking around he was
he was embarrassed and frustrated he's
like i'm sorry dom i was like oh that's
sort of fine
and we're going under these little
subways and all into these little
alleyways we ended up not being able to
find it
and he said i i think i've blown it i
was like you know what it's not a big
deal we'll go back to the hotel so we
went back to the hotel
that night we went out with uh
kelly osbourne and what was her brother
called
jack jack jack osborne for dinner
went out had dinner had a few drinks
whatever and then i said i'm gonna i'm
gonna flag because the next day we were
working so i i headed home and i
remember being in
this car that had been ordered for me
for the night which was a
you know an s-class mercedes like you
know all the bells and whistles
driving silently through the tokyo
streets and i'm thinking
okay so today you got up late you tried
to go see brian wilson from the beach
boys record a song and then you end up
going out for dinner with the osbournes
and you flagged early so that you can
get up early
early the next day like life life is
bizarre
it becomes a trip i remember i was with
sharon and uh
sheryl underwood and and and ozzy at the
beverly hotel and a woman comes up you
know
you can see where they were attractive
in the time and you look back and
and she's like oh ozzie you know do you
remember me
you know i saw you and and i was your
good mom
and sharon like he doesn't remember your
love you know
she goes can i take a picture of us and
share like no we're not taking any
pictures and then she's
you know she leaves you like you can
just see him go how's he do you even
know
he's like exactly
he's like i don't think he remembers her
uh but you know you could hear him
saying like i don't know what i am
you know you're like but it hap i mean
imagine because he's obviously he's got
the hair
yeah he always has the glasses and then
she's there
but it used to be i think you guys
have been victim of falling victim of
this where if you were eating it was off
limits like if you're playing
tag and you're holding on to the poll
i'm free yeah this is a free zone
they don't care if you're eating they
don't care if your kid is freaking out
they don't care if you're discussing
something with your wife face to face
where it looks like you know
i better not bother him yeah anyone else
they would not say a word they come in
now at
at all times yeah for pictures and
i think even sometimes i guess you guys
know they're taking a picture when you
when you
you don't know they're taking a picture
of you or videotaping you because
everybody has one but
yeah yeah i i have friends whenever if i
go to cafes or bars or family
who you know lean over to me at a
certain point they'll be like
there's someone uh just to your left who
i think recognizes you and i'll be like
i've seen them like 20 minutes ago
and i'm managing the situation like i
know when i need to go over and say hey
do you want to have a picture
let's get out of the way and i know
where the exits are and i know where the
entrances are and i know where i need to
get to if it gets really hectic i can
jump into the kitchen
i know all of those places so what's
happened with me over the years is
i've been able to become very adept at
socially managing situations because
if i'm with my friends it's not
something that i need to think about but
any random stranger if someone comes
over to me i'll be like
okay so this guy's he's about 175
looks like he goes to the gym if i get
into an argument with him i'm probably
gonna lose this fight so i'm going to
you know
talk and he's drunk he's a little
belligerent i'm going to sign his thing
and
you know have a little drink in him
someone else comes over who's
you know seems like they're going to
linger on how do we manage that
the people around me are always trying
to protect me we can take care of it and
i always remind them look
i've been in this situation thousands of
times and i know how to manage it
my mum and dad it's kind of a unique
situation for them like oh we'll go over
and speak to them no no no
let me speak to them i'll know what to
do you know so you must be a
an expert but it is it is a bit you know
you would do a project
and that would be the end of the project
but now it's not you guys are extensions
of
of this project right yeah and when
people see you wherever they see you
wherever you are you're still part of
the project it's like playing for i mean
i guess if you were
playing for the chicago bulls and
wherever you went
you were still a chicago bull you know
michael jordan
rodman right and those guys like that it
also gets bigger over the years right
as you know it's been better over the
years lord the rings was a huge deal and
it was a smash hit and all that kind of
stuff but i would argue
that in 2003 when returning the king
came out
at the big apex of of that movie moment
it's not as big a feeling as maybe like
like 2006 it's starting to ebb
and people like oh yeah lord the rings
yeah i've seen it it was a big deal at
the cinema i'm kind of over it but by
the time you get back to like
2015 2020 now it's become part of the
classic
yes yeah all these we we we left a
message for
someone today who was was he 12 when he
saw the figure yeah yeah
so he was 12 when he saw a fellowship of
the ring so that for him is
it's his movie going experience oh yeah
i mean i'm that's that's more my
generation right
i'm the young one in the world what is
it to you know
when you've seen people who have been
like tremendous fans
like because it fills so much of their i
remember one time i was on arsenio
and then i was in orchard park right
outside of chicago
and a guy bro bought me a uh foster's
the log of the can and he's sitting
there and he and i were drinking it and
i was on arsenio like on the
this was early 90s and he said to me i
was in my trailer by myself
watching you on wednesday and here we
are on saturday and we're having a beer
together
so you know that people have those lives
man where it takes on
so much of their lives and i think you
do
you have to remember that every person
you meet is a human being
and you can't like you you can't make it
less because it
may be happened like if something was if
you're a
screening or something just because it's
a hundredth person
you've met is the first time that
they've and sometimes it's good for
somebody to remind you
i remember i was staying at one of the
the disney hotels with my son when he
was young
you know seven or eight years old and
something had happened i hadn't
packed something that we needed so i was
in a case
taking something out to put it into
another bag and a young
lady came past and she went oh dominic
monahan
thank you because we get mixed up all
the time
i saw the pictures inside these guys all
the time they're the same sizes
they shaped their heads like a face yeah
yeah and the mary pep inside
everybody and i was doing this thing
and she went oh dominic monahan i said
no no i'm not dominic monahan
and and she went oh really and i went
yeah yeah
and she went okay and she walked away
and my son was really young and he said
why didn't you tell her that you're
billy boyd because she obviously got you
confused and i was like god you're so
right yeah
you know i was like just because i'm in
that moment
doesn't mean that i can't just take a
breath and go
no you're thinking of the other one and
you know
i felt bad about that for about a week
you know that my son had been like
well why didn't you just tell her that
it's the other guy from the other rings
you know when i was when i was leaving a
hbo thing shoot like you know
and you leave and the you know the car
the window
the suv's dark and this guy kind of
waves and i tell the driver hey man
hang on the second mountain you know
pull over get out i said what's up dude
he's like oh man what's up
you know you go hey i take a picture
with you and you're like yeah you take a
picture
and then he puts it on instagram and he
says that
he's in a place where you know
he's lost his like grandmother was his
whole life
and you know he's walking down the
street and he's like i don't know
if you know this and he sees me and they
get out
and you you know you shake hands with
this dude and it you know not that
not that particular but i mean when
people like
our loves are so different because we
love so many things but
in a world like that like where a guy
is suffering or someone lives in it or
someone has that that
it's really most of their you know comic
cons and things
yeah it's like it's so much of their
lives and we can't say for
five minutes yeah and and maybe tell a
story
but we do we know what it is to somebody
yeah yeah but then i think that's that's
what's better about
social media in the realm of
these movies where they're global they
catch on
there's nfts now that'll that'll
you know nfts and then there's way more
ways to collect but way more
ways to stay connected right as well so
so your love is like it's not like
you're loving somebody that can't love
you back you just see all these things
and they make you
love something even more yeah which i
think ultimately is
what's what's beautiful about either
being a comedian or being an actor or
being part of something
that is this global yeah this is held in
such high regard
my thing has always been wherever you
are i'll meet you at that place
so if someone comes at me with the right
intention and they're cool
i will try my danvest to meet you at
that place of course i've been in
situations like billy where
i'm in a rush or something's going on or
i'm stressed out and maybe
maybe i've not been able to meet those
people at that place what i
really like is if someone meets me
below that place and they don't expect
that i can meet them there right
so if someone comes over to me i'm sure
you've had this george i know billy has
this as well
someone will come over and go i don't
even know who you are
but uh that person over there said to
take a picture with you
and i'll go okay well let's not do that
then
because clearly you don't want to take a
picture with me
and it's only your friend that has
instructions
so why don't we give it a pass and they
go no no no i wanna oh now you wanna
take a picture
i'm always gonna call people out on
their [ __ ] if you don't have any of that
[ __ ] let's take a picture let's have fun
we'll tell a story we'll go
but i'll meet you at that place and i
think
a lot of times with actors performers
comics whatever
someone thinks well i own them i saw
them on tv i own them they're mine
no you don't i'm a human being as well
on my own journey having my own
experience living my own life
so come at me correctly and we'll have
an experience
outside of that it's it's all a gamble
you know
because i could be in a bad mood or they
could be invited i played golf with a
guy in san francisco at the san
francisco com
uh uh golf club historic play in san
francisco
guy was a talker on the first hole
the third guy we were playing with i
said okay so your job today is to stay
between me and him because he's going to
talk my ear off
all day but just stay in between us so
he's talking about
he played with michael jordan once and
he was saying how great he was and then
on the 18th hole there's 25 people
waiting for
michael jordan right and they only
played together once
and because he called ahead and said
i'm playing with michael jordan and
michael jordan was like
oh man really so he was nice and then he
left
and then i told the dude do you know why
you didn't play golf with michael jordan
twice
and he said why is that and i said
because because you called all those
people
and yeah and they were waiting for him
at the 18th he goes no no he was cool
i said do you know why he only played
gold with michael jordan once right
because if there would have been nobody
there he'd come back right that's his
job to be cool that's what he gets paid
for
you know there's consequences if he's
not cool right right
absolutely he was cool but he just
didn't need a gallery but
you know such and such i thank you guys
both man really
hey man it's good
i mean you guys have such great
camaraderie together yeah
i think we've been hanging out for a
while now you know and we just thought
you know it seemed like a podcast seemed
like the
the natural thing because we can do this
so whatever we're doing during the week
we can say oh wow did you watch that tv
show we can talk about it
as well as getting you know friends from
other rings and all that
yeah it just seems like that it just
seemed like a fun thing
i think for fans it's a perfect it's a
perfect thing for people who are fans
and
fans of yours it's very honest doesn't
it it's very immediate and honest and
then you got the
best promo because it looked like you
guys were in two different parts of the
world
yeah and you guys walked over you're
like
we shot that in billy's house billy's
son billy's son
shot that for us which is brilliant it
really was it's really good
because every time you see it it looks
like i think there's like ocean behind
here
the feedback that we're getting right
now which is something that billy and i
really respond to is of course
people love lord of the rings and they
know that they're going to get a little
bit of load rings
each episode but what seems to be the
case from the feedback that we're
getting
is that people just want to get to know
billy and i
more than anything else so very often
people like oh we didn't realize that
you were mary and pippin in real life
you guys are just
hanging out in real life doing your
thing of course in every episode we
will touch upon lord of the rings
because that's how bills and i got to
know each other but
we very often move off into different
directions that people seem to
love these like sure you know different
areas that we're going to
um yeah it's really fun i mean you guys
have a tremendous sense of humor
together but also very unique
individually you know
right yeah right and you know he and i
did walking with herb and
yeah you know in the end it was it was
well done man yeah i really liked it i
loved your performance and now yeah i
really did
sing you know you as well because you
had been you had been a guy
that would have been almost like a um
who is that guy that has never you know
that
never really he's always there but never
quite west would be a guy like that
everyone that i think darren clark was a
guy that i admire
breaking my mind
[Laughter]
that's terrible i know no disrespect
if it's a horse in a race that always
comes second it's a nearly ran
they nearly won but they just
i just noticed you've got a gnome there
i never know
yeah because you've got a real kind of
in that movie a real
specific spirit they would you know
somebody said to me
i never considered you know george lopez
a messenger of god
i think god has a lot of messengers to
deliver the message
a lot of different ways yeah yeah you
know i i grew up uh
around a lot of um my grandmother would
call him harry krishna she thought
everybody that was mauled
wearing wearing a sash wrapped around no
matter what color that was just orange
it wasn't the usc trojan colors you know
uh gold and
and and whatever the crimson and gold
um but everywhere i moved to in my life
they were always
the buddhists were always around right
yeah so then kind of toward the
end of the 2000s i decided to look into
it and
i've seen the dalai lama in person i
spoke at his 80th birthday party and
it's made me a much i don't have much
anxiety or angst or i'm not concerned
about
the things that have happened or i'm not
as worried about things that haven't
happened
yeah yeah and it's to that it's
important yeah i like to take
different pieces from from different
cultures and
different religions and stuff but it
seems to me over the years that
the the kind of tomes of practice more
than anything else that i've taken have
been buddhists
you know the fact that they are kind to
animals the fact that they
care about each other the fact that they
kind of want to make sure that
you know other people are being treated
in the same way that they are being
treated which i guess is the golden rule
for a lot of religions but
the dalai lama seems to be a pretty cool
cat at the end yeah
they hold no judgment but i also know
that
when this dalai lama passes
that i believe that the buddhists will
not have
a dalai lama in body for it'll be a
while because they'll usually find
somebody very young i think the downtown
was 15.
right so when they do identify who is
the 15th
they're going to kind of keep them under
wraps because they think it might be
a bit too much responsibility for
someone young
so they'll wait till he gets a little
bit older and then reveal
himself this one's still going yeah yeah
release like release his first album on
instagram
recording until they decided to release
the first album i think it's probably a
good idea
he was 15 14. and then he had a brother
with china that they tried to
make his brother turn against him and
then right the brother said hey man
they're they're coming to get you
it's a lot of pressure man what an
extraordinary life he's led
yeah and what an example he's set you
know with all of those pressures and all
of those
you know chances where he could say i'm
done with this i'm not going to do it
for him to stick to that discipline what
a fascinating human
and i met sting with the dalai lama in
boston and he said
i'm sting he didn't say i'm gordon okay
so he
even even in the light of them
i love it i said oh okay i'm next to him
i'm george i'm sting
all right fair enough you know the dalai
lama's right there
yeah he sees you he knows you sees you
good luck on your podcast
thank you thank you great hanging out
cheers man thank you
you